on s'en doute cette haute couture ne
s'adresse qu'à un petit nombre de femmes
fortunées les journalistes spécialisés
les évalue à peu près 2000
reste que les présentations de mode
selon la partie la plus voyante de toute
une industrie à la fois prospère est
indispensable à la célèbre image de
marque française est intéressante pour
le ministère des finances
hélène oerlikon poursuit son enquête
molina français fourrure bison ce modèle
vaut 45 me le prends comme ça c'est un
modèle en cachemire gora plus fourrure
et ce modèle e vo 70 ans
la moselle également les nages et 100
l'école bien entendu ça lodève pétrole
très chaud mais sarah fortement la haute
couture en france et inspecteur
autonomie dussopt porte bien très bien
son chiffre d'affaires dans l'hexagone
270 millions de francs il a augmenté de
35% en 84 à l'étranger grâce à ces vingt
mille boutiques et filiales
la haute couture a atteint un chiffre
d'affaires de 15 milliards de francs
il faut dire que 90% de ses créations
s'exporte les principaux acheteurs la
grande europe
les états unis et le japon je crois que
les étrangers soient avoir des choses
exceptionnelles
or la couture part essentielle c'est une
chose exceptionnelle puisque c'est un
produit qui effraie spécialement podium
données et sur mesure alors de
prêt-à-porter vous l'achetez tout le
monde peut acheter le même prêt-à-porter
la poussée on peut directement 3000
personnes blessées ne pas trop faire
elle dynamise plusieurs secteurs
économiques
atelier de fabrication prêt à porter il
ya sextile accessoires divers de la
chaussure cosmétiques en passant par la
lingerie et la lunetterie
bilan trois cent mille personnes
travaillent peu rêve c'est la première
industrie française